the jurgen experience ortega
this last fight that ortega did i felt
like the
the thing that really was like
surprising to me was not necessarily
that he's like oh now you've trained
striking and you're doing really well
with the striking it was like those
in-between things that he was doing that
i was like
yes i've never i haven't seen that in
most ufc fighters like just
that in between thing that he put the
glue together to
he wasn't leaving any holes there's no
holes yeah no no holes yeah it was
brilliant it was a
masterful performance yeah because that
guy the korean zombie
chan sun jung is very he's dangerous
very dangerous
and brian neutralized him he neutralized
everything and he looked so
smooth and professional like everything
he was doing looked so good
and uh the korean zombie said he he
doesn't remember anything of the last
three rounds
doesn't remember them because remember
he got hit with that backspin elbow yeah
yeah he got ko'd and apparently he was
just on autopilot for the rest of the
fight doesn't remember he says he's very
embarrassed doesn't even remember the
fight
wow yeah that happens sometimes guys get
ko'd and they'll go back to their corner
they're like is it the second round it's
the fifth round
and like it is yeah it's the fifth round
come on man you're losing the fight like
i am
right i thought it just started like
they literally don't remember fights
and it's because they're they they're
literally concussed
while they're inside the ring episodes
of the joe rogan experience are now
free on spotify that's right they're
free
from september 1st to december 1st
they're going to be available everywhere
but after december 1st they will only be
available on spotify but they will be
free that includes the video the video
will also be there
it'll also be free that's all we're
asking just go download spotify
much love